thank you madam president I thank you
all for first of all having expressed
collectively what to me is the most
important element which is full
solidarity with one of our member states
with typers and this unity is needed
because it is constantly tested from the
outside and also from the inside from
time to time and I believe it is a
fundamental key vital element of our
being together the basic fact that if
the right
if the sovereignty of one of our member
states is violated as it is the case in
this moment with this Turkish drilling
activities the rest of the European
Union has to come together and not only
show solidarity but also act in
solidarity with Cyprus and this is why
for me it has been key all over this
months I would say all over these years
to keep a constant contact and
coordination which happens itself with
one of our Member States and design the
way in which we could react and shape
the common reaction together with with
cyber's one question I would like to
come back to which is what next the
framework is now established which means
that's now Member States can and I would
expect that they would present proposals
for names both of individuals and
entities that then would be analyzed on
the basis of solid legal basis you know
that our sanction system is based on
elements that need to resist the tests
of court judging in case they are
appealed against so member states are
now going to present proposals for names
of individuals and entities this is
going than to be analyzed by member
states themselves through our council
procedures and by unanimity the member
state the council is going to adopt the
further steps so this is what I would
expect to happen next
this can be going very fast or slower
depending on different bodies and
depending obviously on
also the overall environment because
what I'm I want to stress here is this I
said it also in the beginning sanctions
and the framework for introducing
sanctions is an instrument to put
pressure and to try and provoke a change
the objective here is to change the
attitudes stop the drillings and I'm
surprised that not many of you have
underlined this try to help the UN
finding what would be the real solution
would be the settlement of the Cyprus
issue this would be and a United Cyprus
inside the European Union this would be
the game changer not only for the
drilling activities but also and mainly
for Cyprus itself and for the European
Union and for the entire region so this
is why I referred to the upcoming
meeting that doTERRA has convened at the
end of this month it is I believe
important for us to constantly stress
this in this moment that the European
Union is continuing to look at that
solution at that framework at the UN
Framework as the real solution for this
issue and for the settlement as such and
that we are ready to accompany that
obviously and we have discussed this
with our Turkish counterparts several
times including in the recent months
including at my level obviously these
activities go in the opposite direction
and this is an additional reason why and
we want to see them stopping and first
and foremost let me stress it once again
to reaffirm that the European Union is a
United in defense of the sovereignty of
one of our member states thank you
Virgin Queen semi come the bottom